ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show from los angeles california
we are on the road in irvine
doing shows in orange county the
birthplace of reality tv and subprime
mortgages
not the birthplace of reality tv but the
birthplace of the genre of reality
tv that uh we know now
um uh the real housewives of orange
county
started there and uh
subprime mortgages started there in
irvine
california irvine correct me if i'm
wrong it's one of the only
cities that is named after the company
that's correct yeah and that's still
very much
the um the feel
of irvine california yeah what is
generally known as the city of irvine is
named after
pioneering rancher james irvine oh
but it's through his corporation through
irvine's 40 years of incorporation
well no that doesn't mean anything the
irvine company
oh the irvine company is that why irvine
was named
i believe so yes by james irvine and
then they named the city irvine after
the company
okay well countrywide home loans start
at nirvine which was the
i believe the largest subprime
mortgage lender on the planet
i don't know if that's the case but it
was i believe it was
um and then countrywide uh
expanded but i believe the beginning of
countrywide
was in irvine california
and the two biggest
areas for subprime mortgage banks were
irvine california and long island new
york
and they are the same place essentially
you have a lot of rich people
um you have a lot of people that
are always willing to jump into whatever
the latest scam is
a lot of different types of sales people
and
long island and irvine you know they're
both beach
you know communities um orange county
and long island rather not irvine but
orange county and long island
are very similar the types of people
they're very similar
uh conservative politically um
there's there's not a lot of culture in
orange county
there's no culture in long island
there's none in orange county either
um and you know the the people are
uh differ slightly but it's a very
similar makeup of human beings
a lot of tribal tattoos not a lot of
reading
a lot of people with boats uh irvine has
more like rock
churches you know orange county sorry i
keep saying irvine but
irvine's nothing it's a few buildings
right but orange county's got a lot of
like
churches where people go and they rock
out um
you know and they're just there and
they're you know they married an
ex-baseball player and
they're just feeling it and jesus loves
them jesus wants them to have another
boat
jesus wants him to be rich like mosaic
is one of those churches where
people just just get in there and the
tits are out
and the guys are there and their shirts
are unbuttoned down you could
you know you could see the gym you could
see the gains and they're in there and
they're just worshiping the lord and
jesus
wants money christ wants you to do well
that's orange county ethos they moved
out of la
and they're like i'm going to find jesus
and
that's where all the tick tock kids will
eventually end up they go to find jesus
down in orange county 10 years later
that's what happens
and uh and the shows have been really
not great
they've not been fun at all i don't
think i'll ever go back i'm
shocked at how how like bad they've been
even though people are having a good
time yeah yeah
i'm not having a good time and my life
is about me
so a lot of people like well i enjoyed
it but i don't care what you enjoyed
i want to have fun and coming from
boston where comedy is just it's
amazing to uh orange county and the room
is
the room that we're in is big it's a big
room and you know it's hard to
to to feel like you're doing well even
though you are
uh it's a big dave and buster's really
that we're performing it
you know it's got what is it got 2 000
seats or
i mean it's stupid it's really big it's
big next to like a holistic people are
watching me on screens that are in the
room they're watching me on screens
and then uh and you know i got to hang
out with people in l.a i don't know if
i'm
we're going to come back here i don't
know either it's not been a good few
days
it's really not been good uh you get
away from this mental illness for a
while
and then you come back to it and you
realize it's it's actually not
preferable to anywhere else it's really
not there's like a few restaurants i
like but that's it
you know the guy opening for me goes
like this he goes uh he's like dude do
you think you know like la guy goes
do you think like you'll have like a
later career
as an actor like daniel day lewis
and i said excuse me are you asking
me if i think that later on in my life
i will have a career similar to
one of the greatest actors that's ever
lived daniel day-lewis
no are you going to be daniel day-lewis
is that part of your plan we're telling
jokes
in a mall in irvine california
but this is the disease here
you know the manager of the club comes
in he's got like a mask on he's like
you know your agent came back he goes
they think i'm like some guy working
here but i'm the regional manager they
don't know that
hey who gives a [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
it's chuck e cheese it's a comedy club
it's chuck e cheese
well i mean you have a [ __ ] bandana
over your face nobody knows who you are
you know i mean
i never say anything good about my
agents but in this case they're in the
right
you can't demand that people respect you
if
if you're covered in uh darth vader mask
and nobody can tell who you are
it's it's not a rational belief
you hear that the sirens i mean
this may not be it i gotta be honest i
don't know if we're coming back
i don't know we're not coming back till
next year and it may not even be then
[Laughter]
something's different here it's not good
masks are back on the variants are back
you know i just want to
i just want to get to a point where you
can get through this and simone biles
uh dropped out of the uh olympics she is
a gymnast
uh considered the greatest of all time
yes and
uh her sister tweeted y'all are all
about mental health
until it no longer benefits you i can't
imagine being that inconsiderate whoo
she's basically saying lay off her
sister right lay off simone and i
believe that too
listen the olympics is a scam and a
waste of everyone's time
i don't care who shows up to work why
are we even having it this year
it's dumb why would we care about
excellence in athletics we care about it
literally
nowhere else and i get it she's having
mental problems the problem with
that i have now with what i consider to
be
the fetishization of
mental health is this number one
i've been very clear about my own circ
my own family
my mother being a schizophrenic and that
uh impacting the way that i feel
about mental health because i see a lot
of people
on social media that have diagnosed
themself
with many different disorders i don't
know
how accurate they are i don't think it's
a good idea to diagnose yourself
from an instagram post and read that and
go that sounds like me on that now
it's becoming a weird identity for
people and i'm not saying there aren't
legitimate instances
of mental health but athletes this is my
thing with athletes
and i got to be careful about how i say
this because it's going to come off
uh i don't know how it'll come off
when it comes to athletes and mental
health
i think the biggest thing to consider
here
is that athletes don't have
minds
do you see what i mean that is
not why we know who they are
they aren't shouldn't why are we telling
them
to be self-actualized human beings
their body is their temple and their
mind only works
as the operating system of their body
their mind should not be this
uh you know
flourishing and important part of what
they do
their mind should be uh simply like
taking order giving orders to their body
so when we have somebody like simone
biles
um having these problems um
we we we we have to really look at
um are we telling athletes
to think too much are we telling them
to be too involved
in their in their own you're you're
supposed you're not supposed to think
too much
about what you're doing because it's
stupid
[Music]
it's dumb you balance on a bar
it's dumb if you think
too much about it you will lose your
mind and go insane
you're getting millions and millions of
dollars to do something that's
essentially
silly it's silly
you're you're doing a tumba salt
it's not something that you should spend
an inordinate amount of time
thinking about truly you whether you're
throwing a basketball into a hoop
or throwing a ball down all of it is
silly it's important we need it it
distracts people
from the pandemic and the wars and the
economy and the no health care
and the no jobs and their kids on heroin
and the town's falling apart and
violence is in the street
it distracts them you need that
but i think the people that are great
athletes i'm sure some of them have been
reasonably intelligent but the vast
majority of people
that get really good at sports do so
because their minds
are not the thing that drives them in
life
and nor should they be now there are
certain sports
where obviously it is important but
again
like god people can say oh golf you got
to have a strong mind to compete in golf
i yes but they're idiots
if you get any of the guys on the pga
tour and talk to them they're not smart
none of them are intelligent they're not
how can you be intelligent
you have to devote so much of your life
to swinging a club and hitting a ball in
a hole
you can't be smart you literally cannot
they're not
smart people none of them
when you see an athlete that's like can
string a sense together you're floored
because you don't expect that nor should
you
they get their enjoyment out of life
from competition
competing and they need to have mental
toughness
i'm not saying this woman should be
castigated but i'm also not saying she
should be celebrated
um for her issues and her problems
um mental toughness is part of
athletics it has been for a long time
and the reason
that the greatest players have been able
to be mentally tough
is because a lot of them are stupid
that's
what that's the point
they don't think that much
mental illness is very common with
people that have a lot of thoughts
if you can quiet your mind quiet
it down so that you can like you know
really become a machine
that's how you get to be a great athlete
you know i mean
that's what people are going to be
offended at this
oh you're fat you don't know what
athletics is uh
you're an idiot hey hey
they're [ __ ]
but they're great that's the point
the point is that they're stupid people
who are able to do an amazing thing
physically
and we pay them lots of money if they
weren't able to
do that what would they be doing
can i ask you that if athletes were not
able to do
athletic things what would they be doing
ceo
would they be running a hospital no
they wouldn't be they're doing this
because they're
they're driven by the need to compete
and they're in great shape
and they have mental toughness they have
to be
tough mental toughness is
you stupidity becomes a virtue
in athletics and i don't mean you can't
be savvy
and you can't be uh you know
uh whatever funny or but i'm talking
about real intelligence here
uh these people don't have it nor should
they the vast majority of them i agree
not not all of them there's some of them
that are very smart but
the vast majority of them so i don't
care what this woman does or not the
gymnastics to me shouldn't even be legal
it's a sport of pedophiles
where they stunt a girl's growth and
they keep them like little dolls
it's insane i mean this this poor woman
went through all kinds of horror
the guy just molested the thousands of
them larry nassar and it's so
rampant that no one cared because it's
in gymnastics it's assumed that it's a
sport for pedophiles
like when those girls came home and said
i was molested their parents were like
yeah
don't you want to be a gymnast i thought
you wanted to be a gymnast
that's what it is you get molested and
you know you don't eat and you don't
grow and you stay
like you look like a little doll you
ever see these people
it's disgusting it's disgusting when you
look at them
they're tiny they're literally this big
they're tiny little people and
and it's not healthy at all
it's not healthy
well these are children now but gymnasts
it stuns their growth i don't know why
somebody that's smarter than me can
explain that but it does and that's why
pedophiles like to coach gymnastics
because nobody ever grows up this is a
fact
okay there are some arguments that link
high-intensity gymnastics training
during puberty with delayed growth
the theory is that young people
undertaking such high levels of
gymnastics training
are likely to develop overuse injuries
and are at risk of causing stress to
growing bones and growth plates
every we all know the gymnasts they're
all tiny
so i am i am i am
deeply sympathetic to whatever this girl
has gone through and
is going through and also men that are
doing gymnastics are just men that don't
have the guts to come out of the closet
there's not one heterosexual male in
gymnastics
it's just a fact everyone doing
gymnastics is gay
you know the women don't have a
sexuality because they're just forever
children
have you ever seen the i'm gonna get in
so much trouble
but have you ever seen after they win
their teams like hugging them but it's
very childlike
and they have like teddy bears and stuff
it's freak [ __ ]
it's legit freak [ __ ] if you think i'm
wrong
go watch some of the old olympics where
they win
they're like 19 you know but they're
like children
and like the coaches carrying them
around and they have a teddy bear
it's freak [ __ ] it's [ __ ] up it's not
right
it's not right it should be banned they
should replace it with some type of
twerking or freestyle dance you know
it's not good
and you know i just i'm saying that and
male gymnast
gymnasts are gay they're gay men who
are are unable to tell the world that
they suck [ __ ] and they like to have
penises in their ass
or they like to put a penis in another
man's ass so instead of that
they do like the you know i don't know
the [ __ ] the the
the parallel bar what are they what are
these events even called
i know what they are the bars the bars
let me see i mean the the rings uh
they're strong these men but they
imagine [ __ ] them
when male gymnasts look at each other
they want to
[ __ ] each other to death when a male
gymnast sees another male gymnast
they want to [ __ ] each other to death
they want to
rip the skin off each other i mean
this is what it is they want to like
land on a [ __ ] like they want to like do
the final jump where they stick the
landing
they want to stick the landing right on
another guy's [ __ ]
they're gay and that's great
i don't i don't i i mean they're hot
they're good-looking men
um but they're they're gay and simone
biles is it people are upset at her
because
she dropped out of the team comp which
again
who gives a [ __ ] but i would have rather
if she competed and lost
because i think it's funny when people
phone it in
it's much better to me just phone it in
she's like well
i could hurt myself because a lot of the
the the moves i'm doing are have a high
degree of difficulty
which is true and she has the twisties
the the twists
explain that so the the twisties didn't
you get that in golf
uh no that's the yips but you you had
the yips and golf that's why you're not
on the tour
because you weren't mentally strong you
know why because you're not that dumb
no this is a fact thank you if you were
dumber
you'd have like you'd be like jesus said
hit the ball and you'd live
in orange county you turned the brain
off yeah you got to turn the brain
off you have to turn your brain off and
you weren't able to do it
because you knew that that was not your
destiny your destiny was greatness like
what we're doing here
you know so she's a studio she's
greatness so the twisted liquid
it's supposed to be like a version of
like vertigo where like when she's doing
a twist
then she could think she's doing a flip
and then she could just land on her head
and just die essentially well my
argument is don't do any of that
don't do any of the hard [ __ ] go out
there and just kind of be like
like don't you don't have to do that
scale it back
don't do any of the olympic level stuff
what if she just went out and twerked on
the floor
in a shirt that said i love china
i would do you know how much i would
support her do you know
how much i would support this woman
publicly use you use
any of my social capital whatever it is
to support this woman if she said i'm
having a mental health problem
i'm gonna go out and just rip my shirt
off it's gonna say i love china
and then i'm just gonna twerk
i would be like [ __ ] yeah but this is
what i mean about athletes we're
we're confusing these people by telling
them that they should
think and they should not athletes
like actors like singer like you know
and and even comedians like i get it
like
so many comics who have tried to be
intelligent over the last few years
have just destroyed their careers um we
need to go back to a world where smart
people can go
and be smart somewhere and everybody
else needs to just
realize what they're good at and stop
trying to be an expert in 19 different
things she this
woman should not even know what her mind
is doing
truly she shouldn't her
success is built on her ability she is
the greatest gymnast of all time
there's no one better than her but in
order to keep that going but she's
probably getting older and she's
starting to realize that it doesn't
matter
see this is what i'm getting to but i
just shut my emotions off
otherwise i go in uh with the gun and i
kill everyone because that's what she's
gay
her mental health is starting to
deteriorate because she's realizing that
it's all for nothing it's [ __ ] who
cares
yes she became the goat yes you became
the best but the happiest people in this
country are disgusting fat
sloths who've never held themselves to
any standard that's truly the meaning of
life
to be little more than bacteria which is
what the majority of people are
they're just bacterial organisms just
existing right
they're mold essentially and this woman
has tried to be great her entire life
flips and splits and dips and twists and
[ __ ]
all the time and her [ __ ] coach is
touching her she's gotta be like
[ __ ] you and she's gonna deal with her
family and her envious friends
and all the scumbags she's got to get
great and great and better and better
and better and beat this [ __ ] and this
[ __ ] and this white [ __ ] and the
russians
got to beat the [ __ ] russians even
though we didn't do it this time but you
know those [ __ ] dykes come over here
those russians they're not [ __ ]
around right
i mean those people are literally
tortured it's state policy
to torture gymnast abu ghraib style
until they're [ __ ] great
and this [ __ ] has got to get through
all of that to become the goat and then
you realize it doesn't
[ __ ] matter you're not happier
you're not better off that's when it
starts to unravel
you start to go [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
that's when you got to shut it off shut
it off
you got to do it simone because it it if
you start questioning it
if you start going should i have done
all this would i have been happier
should i have just
would i've should i've i can't believe
what do i do what do i do now
shut it off and do the flip
we make our choices simone we make our
choices i made the choice to do this
i didn't want to do this today i i i i
don't know that i've ever wanted to do
this ever in my life
but it's what i do i can't start
thinking about it
now i imagine that on the way i would
drive my car off a
[ __ ] you know off a hill in l.a or
[ __ ] into a ravine or something if i
started thinking about
my life stop thinking about your life
just do the thing that you've learned to
do because
we no no nobody gets out of this alive
you know and that that's my issue but
you know there's
there's bad actors out there they're
gonna exploit this mental health [ __ ]
and use it
as a reason to usher in mediocrity that
[ __ ] naomi osaka
who didn't want to do the interviews
shut the [ __ ] up do the [ __ ]
interviews you dumb [ __ ]
do you know how much money you're making
to play [ __ ] tennis tennis is
stupid it's a stupid sport for racist
white people
okay and somehow you figured out a way
to dominate that sport
more power to you but shut the [ __ ] up
you don't want to do interviews i don't
want to do a lot of [ __ ] but i [ __ ]
do it
enough stop babying these stupid [ __ ]
idiots
truly enough kick her out
give a [ __ ] let her do something else go
be a doctor if you don't want to do it
like
it's just i'm sick of hearing this [ __ ]
you're supposed to be you're supposed to
enjoy the interviews
because you're supposed to sit there and
forget the last one and you forget
because you're an idiot
you're dumb you're the reason that you
[ __ ] do well as you're dumb
it's not hard it is but it's not you're
a [ __ ]
stop trying to be intelligent
what are you gonna put on a lab coat and
do do gene sequencing
you hit a ball over a net
and you're the best at it because you're
stupid
because you don't question why you do it
because your body is your temple your
mind your mind the body just
wants to compete give it that endorphin
rush
stop trying to think you're going to
ruin your life
do you know how many people i've seen
ruin their life because they think
people are sitting in marriages they go
you know i actually don't think this is
and then they're it's worse then they
get divorced and on the other side of
that it's worse
you know i'm just i i just i've had
enough with the mental health my mother
is a legit mental patient she's in a
[ __ ] mental institution
she she's [ __ ] crazy okay
and do you know what genuinely mentally
ill people think
they think they should be in the
olympics
ladies and gentlemen better help better
help i'll tell you right now a lot of
people are suffering from anxiety
depression
better help is an online counseling
service with licensed professionals that
are willing
to help you you can reach out 24 hours a
day you'll get start communicating
in under 48 hours betterhelp wants you
to start living a happier life
so many people have been using better
health they're recruiting additional
counselors in all
50 states if you don't like a council
you can switch it's easy they have types
of treatment that may not be available
in your physical world
you'll get friendly and thoughtful
responses you can schedule weekly or
video phone sessions so you don't ever
have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy
better help is communicated to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so that they make it easy
i'm telling you right now mental health
is all the rage right now you got to be
mentally fit
mentally healthy and the way to do that
is better health better help
we've given up on physical health and
now we're doing mental health and i
think that's great
mental health go to betterhelp.com timd
that's betterhelp.com
t-i-m-d join the over one million people
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
you're going to love it this podcast is
sponsored by better help
and tim dillon show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
tim d magic spoon cereal how much do i
have to talk about magic spoon i mean
it's great it's got zeros grams of sugar
14 grams of protein and only four net
grams of carbs in each serving only 140
calories are serving it's keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free low carb
you can build your own box and get a
variety pack with available flavors
cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter blueberry cinnamon
i'm telling you magic spoon is so
cool they're bringing back two super
popular flavors cookies and cream and
maple waffle permanently
wow isn't that crazy you should get
these flavors again you should try them
cookies and cream and maple waffle
they're coming back permanently
magicspoon.com tim dillon to grab your
delicious cereal and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code tim
dillon at checkout to save five dollars
off your order
magicspoon.com tim dillon the grape grab
your delicious cereal and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code tim
dillon at checkout to save five dollars
off your order
magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed by 100 happiness
guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked magicspoon.com tim dillon
use that code to save five dollars off
your order
i wanted to talk about my favorite story
um of the week a guy
who is um one of his daughters or
sons i forget was in parkland
oh yes and he uh
believed or came to be of the belief
that the parkland shooting
was a hoax and the quote here from the
new york post is that parkland survivor
says dad has turned to q on conspiracies
and thinks massacre was a hoax
if this country
had any balls if the entertainment
industry
had any balls
is that not a reality show that you're
watching
is that not a reality show that you do
not miss
every single time it's on you would
leave
family engagements you might leave uh
your wife giving birth
to see the end of an episode of that
show
where a survivor of the parkland
shooting and her father
argued about whether it happened or not
am i the only one that wants to see this
in real time
can we set up a debate because i don't
know that i'm gonna side with the girl
she might be a [ __ ]
and in fact the fact that the father
believes this to me means that the child
is like a [ __ ]
you've gotta really suck for your dad to
choose alex jones over you
truly but she may
but i wanna see it i wanna see more
about it a teen who claims to be a
survivor of the high school shooting in
parkland florida
is being traumatized all over again by
his father oh him
a q a non-believer says the massacre is
just a hoax the student
who recently graduated said his dad's
conspiracy theories which surfaced after
he became a devotee of q anon
have now caused a rift in the family he
told the post on monday
he was always an avid trump supporter
and after the pandemic into queue
the man who asked to remain anonymous
wrote in an email so he was already
predisposed to falling into
the fake news crowd and trusting people
like marjorie taylor green
so it's what's that's what started the
whole thing
um people have told me that it may be a
coping mechanism to be able to deal with
what happened but i don't know the man
added
i just love the idea of a dinner tape
like a father at dinner and
you know the kids like do you have any
idea what i've been through
and your father's like you're still
going you're still going with that story
you're still doing that you're gonna
look
me in the face and tell me
that there was a shooting at your school
you're gonna tell me that
after everything i know after everything
that you know i know
who's paying you whose payroll are you
on
i know it's not the majority but anyone
accusing me of using my trauma so this
is the person that
is uh this is their reddit thread that
went viral this is
r slash q and on casualties i know it's
not the majority but anyone accusing me
of using my own trauma to spin a story
[ __ ] you this was literally just a
spur-of-the-moment rant
i thought it would reach at most a
couple of hundred upvotes i'd never
planned this blowing up
i never contacted the media what the
[ __ ] would i get out of this
this is really [ __ ] important to me
because however terrible you imagine the
shooting being
double that way too much of my high
school experience was dealing with this
[ __ ] so believe i'd never make light of
it
because you have no idea what the [ __ ]
you're talking about you watch his
interrogation footage
and he seems just like a brain dead
child like [ __ ] who's too [ __ ]
stupid to know what's going on he is
but he's also a literal [ __ ] demon
i've never seen determination like that
my entire life
and there's a lot of people who don't
know so [ __ ] you and this is why
that kid should have done sports
he's talking about who nicholas cruz
yeah about cruz yeah
go through the sub and you might realize
what q anon is capable of doing to their
own family they're delusional [ __ ]
people trapped in a cult
fact they're literally anti-vax nurses
kind of funny
[Laughter]
folks i don't know what you want me to
do if it's funny i have to laugh at it
you know i mean it's funny it's kind of
funny
uh you know there's a variance of
opinions on the vaccine why should
nurses hold them
it is just kind of funny if a nurse is
like whispering in someone's ear like
don't get it
it's funny to me it's funny if you
don't think there's if you if you are of
the belief that we're going to get out
of this
and there's like brighter days ahead
this is all very tough for you to take
but if you've uh settled into um
the idea that uh this is maybe the best
it'll be
hilarious he's done extensive research
on body language it claims he could tell
the shooter is a radical commie actor
who was paid to sacrifice his life in
order to remove our guns
he's questioning why they release the
interrogation footage if not
to further deceive the quote sheep
believing everything they see
he also says the trial will be rigged
and the reason they're talking about the
death penalty
is to prevent him from ever talking just
in case what's really [ __ ] up is that
he knows
i never want to hear about him or see
his face ever again i've been very clear
on that
and i always leave the room when he
starts talking about him nicholas cruz
i keep telling him to please please
[ __ ] stop but there's no reaction or
empathy whatsoever
even burgundy-colored t-shirts what he
wore makes me uncomfortable and he used
to be so understanding he stopped
wearing it around me
that purse is completely gone and i miss
him so [ __ ] much
you're well also are you do you suck as
a person
because it feels very weird that your
dad just went down this rabbit hole if
you weren't a little bit of a piece of
[ __ ] right
you're a real piece of work to be able
to sit here and act like nothing ever
happened if it wasn't a hoax shame on
you for being part of it and putting
your family through it too
he'll say stuff like this straight to my
face he's drinking
oh that's great he'll say this
stuff straight to my face whenever he's
drinking and i wonder if he's
like he's sitting there like this he's
like look at me
how dare you how [ __ ] dare you lie to
your old man
you're a piece of [ __ ] for being part of
it you're
move out hey move out
kid move out maybe leave
i don't know this sounds like a
reasonable time to get your own
apartment
get a roommate buddy
i mean maybe it's time to go your
father's accusing you
of being part of the parkland conspiracy
maybe it's time to leave huh
i can't take more of him berating me
appropriately trying to trigger me to
see if my ptsd is real or not
what does he just walk around the house
with a gun is it real
he's seen me break down and cry my eyes
are multiple times which i've never ever
did before
sometimes i wonder if he's hit his head
or had a [ __ ] stroke because i almost
can't believe it's the same person what
the [ __ ] is q anon doing to people
my breaking point was yesterday when i
borrowed my little brother's ipad
and saw he'd search for some really bad
things related to the shooting
i practically begged my mom to give my
dad an ultimatum to get professional
helper move out
she's really timid and hates
confrontation so all she said
was try not being home as much and wait
it out yeah leave dude
i have no idea how to deal with this
it's too painful for me to keep living
like this hearing his name every single
[ __ ] day being accused of accepting
money to be a part of it
how much did they pay you
[Laughter]
you're gonna lie to your old man how
much did they [ __ ] pay you to be part
of it
you call me piece of [ __ ] your ptsd is
all [ __ ]
you were a part of it try to take my gun
edit even though i've definitely felt
like i don't think getting physical
would do any good at all i
i instead try to remind him to look back
at the text i sent
when i was 100 sure the shooter was
about to enter our classroom
i asked him to look me in the eyes and
still argue i'm able to fake what i
wrote in those messages but no luck
i feel for the kid it's time to move out
i mean listen is it funny
certainly is it horrible yes should you
leave
yes um it's very uh unfortunate your
father is he's been bit
he's feral as i've said uh there's
and by the way it's like obviously i'm
not trying to draw parallel but it's
like
i've had family members where they keep
talking about trump and russia and
they're
you know with the cove they won't you
know they're excited about the next
lockdown and you know they're like
russia sent us the delta virus
so trump can i'm like all right you're
that's liberal
queueing on is you know the the crazy
covet stuff and
and i gotta cover the real thing but you
know some people have lost their [ __ ]
minds we all know that so
um this does seem to present itself in
the q anon movement people
it does and sadly um
the q anon movement has seemingly
attracted some unstable people
and that's unfortunate but i feel bad
for this dude but you gotta move the
[ __ ] out of your crib
bro hit me up at tim j dillon on
instagram
hit me up if you're good-looking you
come stay with me
if you're good-looking you have a home
austin or la wherever i happen to be
you could come stay with me but you know
you got to send me a pic send some pics
send some pics hit me up it is
unfortunate that
he's going through that because you know
he i'm sure your dad feels the text you
sent when the shooter was about to enter
which was probably like hey i may die
right now i love you right oh my god
would i never send that to my family
i would never if i thought i was right
about to die
i would never text my
family because anything i got back
would be so underwhelming
that for those to be the last words i've
read on this planet
like like literally i could imagine like
sending my father a text
that he like half read and i'm like i'm
in school
there's a shooter he's gonna kill us
and i love you and he would just read
like school love you know and then he'd
just write back
enjoy it son
and then i would be like well this is
the last text message i get to read
uh in my life you know i don't know that
i text anyone i wouldn't text him
him and his wife would just go and just
stare in the will so they just
they get excited you know i just would
hate to text him because i knew like
he would just look at her and she'd be
like is it the time
and you'd be like this is not a drill
he'd be like this is not a drill
let's go they'd be so excited you know
they'd come to the hospital and yank the
tubes out of me
but i would never i would never in my
life text my father so at least he
like is close enough with his family at
one time to text yeah yeah yeah his
family which is nice
remember those times don't get greedy
don't get greedy no one's close with
their family their whole life
remember the good times when you loved
them and you texted them that you loved
them
don't get greedy you can't ask
for your dad to not accuse you of being
a crisis actor
that's greed you had the good times
enjoy them and move on and leave you
don't want to start being one of these
people who's just like
me me me selfish selfish selfish
oh i demand that my relationship with my
father is perfect forever
well you cannot you cannot make those
demands
people go through things okay and your
father right now
is having a little bit of a rough patch
okay he's being red-pilled and it's very
tough for him
he's gone it's too much
and what's happening now is he's uh
lashing out at you because you're in the
house
leave and then he'll eventually turn on
your mother and then she'll leave or
you know what is this
well this was one of the edits he goes
another one i've been told
is brain tumor or lead poisoning
apparently it's normal with boomers all
i know
is that he's never been the same since
the shooting the pandemic messed him up
and lately it's just gotten worse
or maybe he actually just had a mental
break and it's gone [ __ ] insane
who knows we'll probably get back with
an update
if i found out why are you not
okay ready go down as for my situation
remember not
that not everyone were on tv like david
i'm just one of the many dealing with
what happened
i came out fine physically but way too
many didn't so a big [ __ ] you to anyone
sending me [ __ ] dms
your time is better spent i didn't send
him a [ __ ] terminal i sent
i sent pick and then question mark pick
pic pick
and it's a throwaway i'm not trying to
get docs crazy i even have to explain
that
sorry if this is long but i got to get
it off my chest yeah and then he goes in
and then he goes into it yeah
sports yeah
that's the whole thing turn it off turn
your mind off yeah
turn your mind off this guy here's
here's what's happening here and i'm
i have a little bit of a background
in um psychology
and it's not a doctorate or anything but
it's enough to talk on youtube
this kid is exhibiting the signs
to me of somebody
who it's very first of all
there's survivors killed when you live
and
other people around you die you have
what they call survivors guilt have you
heard of that yes
it's a legit thing if we're in a car
accident
and there's four of us and three of us
die and and me or you who's everything
if i survive or you survive there's
survivors guilt okay
so you have that okay there's also
another thing which is compounding that
which is making it even harder for this
kid is that i think he does
he feels genuinely guilty that he
participated in a false flag
but i don't think he should because
throughout history these operations have
been used
and it's kind of an honor to be involved
but i think his guilt about
participating in a false flag
has started to override his
uh uh you know sense of self
and he can't repair this relationship
with his father
who's obviously asking good questions
and it's just becoming a problem so i
would say
maybe move out for a little bit and
until you can admit to your father what
you've done
that's what i would do by the way if i
was this kid legit i'd be like yes so i
did it so what [ __ ]
george soros gonna [ __ ] you in your
mouth
how about that i i would drive him more
crazy i'd be like you don't even know
you don't even know who ordered us to do
this
you don't even know you don't even know
what doors you're knocking on dad
we can make people disappear it's like
that line from breaking bad
where um walter white goes hey man if
you think i'm that guy
you know great like i'm the one who
knocks type of thing yeah yeah i think
the kid's got to turn to his dad and go
so you think i participated in that and
you don't fear me
you don't legitimately fear me you think
i was part of something like that
and you don't respect me are you stupid
are you an idiot do you know what i can
do do you know what i can have done
okay just have a little fun with it it's
tough i know it's a hard thing to have
fun with but
i i think that that's the route to go
drive the dad
more crazy tell him that not only did
you do that but you did everything
tell him you did 9 11 when you were
eight
tell them you were integral you were
involved in the night
this is part of when i said like put
jenny slate in jail
because she she came out you know she
had that whole thing with um
big mouth yeah she played a biracial
girl but she acted like she had like
um you know she her apology was like she
had lit a black family's house on fire
like literally her apology she was
voicing a mixed-race character on a
cartoon
her apology was like she had been for
years and years in the clan
and she was coming out to say like my
actions contributed to the eurasia like
um so i think you got to go crazy when
they go woke you go crazy you go put her
in jail it's not enough
so i think here you actually go crazier
than dad and go you don't even know what
i've been involved in
parkland's not even the beginning or the
end of it
okay sit down tell them be like you want
to know how things work
i'm an alien i was born with alien dna
you and mom don't have it that's why i
was recruited
start saying [ __ ] like that or just kind
of go along with it like
you and him discover the parkland
conspiracy together
like it's like a it's a version of like
father-son
bonding but instead of like going
hunting or
camping or golfing you guys hunt
down the real killer it's like i imagine
o.j simpson and his son maybe did
something like that
oh jay and justin he was like hey we
gotta find the guy who did this
and his son's like what oj is like we
gotta find the guy
who did this and his son's like well i
lost a mom i don't want to lose a mom
and a dad
so you got to just go like all right dad
wants to drive around sunday see if we
can find the killer
you go have a nice breakfast you drive
around go where's the killer
where's the killer i think that's what
you got to do here
you just accept that your father like
many people is imperfect
and you just go with that and you just
have whatever relationship with him you
can have
and you guys kind of then go and hunt
down
um the real
killers you know because nicholas cruz
if if your contention is that he was a
patsy
you got to find the people that directed
him to do it so i think there could be a
lot of fun
yeah there could be a lot of fun to be
had but i'm
it's unfortunate that all that is uh
happening blue chew it's a summer love
baby
not so much but it's we'll see gotta
have a penis it works you know what blue
chew is it's got the same prescription
as a viagra and cialis the same
ingredients but you can get it without a
prescription you just go online
uh talk with one of their medical
professionals they will make sure that
you get the
right dose for you okay and it's gonna
be great the best part it's all done
online no visits to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations and no waiting
in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets were made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discrete package
amazing with bluetooth men everywhere
excited to see the postman
because when your package has arrived
your quote package has arrived
they always say first impressions are
important what about lasting impressions
well put so blue chew you have a hard
dick
it's good it's good for everybody
involved it's so important
and and and it's uh it's you know it's
really
um it helps
people become more equal and i believe
in equality
so if everyone is a hard dick they're
equal visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
we thank bluetooth for sponsoring the
podcast
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code td at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code td to receive
your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more deals and
important safety information
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
the podcast
i love these shorts bird dog shorts are
the best they have a built-in silky soft
inner liner that makes underwear
obsolete they're the most comfortable
shorts i've ever worn and it's not even
close
they stole lululemon's designer and now
they're doing it better if you're not
wearing bird dogs this summer then what
the [ __ ] are you doing
every dude needs a pair of bird dogs
okay bird dogs are great i mean they're
shorts and the liner is so comfortable
you truly don't need underwear i know
that they say that
uh but that's actually the case they're
great to wear around the house or to the
beach or really anywhere
if you're going and hanging out with
people you don't want to wear underwear
you could just take the bird dogs off
and show everyone your dick it's perfect
truly
it's great i think it's a good idea
birddogs.com promo code tim dillon and
boom
free bird dogs whistle ball with your
pair of bird dogs
how cool is that you will not take these
things off i promise you
and if you do take them off make sure
it's in the presence of someone who's
asked you to do it have they asked you
to take them off
if they have not leave them on
birddogs.com promo code tim dillon i'm
telling you right now
it's fun you're young and fun or old and
not fun it doesn't matter you wear the
bird dogs they make you better
they make you sharper you feel sporty
and cool you feel
lighter with the bird dog shorts on
you remember those nerf vortex howler
footballs at whistle when you throw them
from when you were a kid yeah it's that
but bird dogs threw their logo on a
genius
oh so you get that thing that's cool so
if you want that and you want the shorts
and you want to support our show which
is the greatest podcast it's ever been
go to birddogs.com b-i-r-d-d-o-g-s
dot com bird dogs dot com and boom you
get a whistle ball
you support the show and you get some
bitchin bad-ass shorts
delta variant back better than ever
lambda gamma phi beta comma sigma
epsilon it's coming back 125
682 breakthrough florida cases remember
when we used to
announce it at the beginning of every
podcast i would go yeah give me the
death numbers
in the world give me the sick we had the
world oh meter yeah and i'd go give me
the sick
give me the dead it's a fun way to get
started and we're back
breakthrough covent cases data shows how
many vaccinated americans have tested
positive
well this is the deal right you get the
vaccine it's supposed to uh
help you in terms of not dying but
you're gonna get it
and you know you take risks whatever
risks you deem appropriate
um i guess this is more this is going to
be like an endemic not a pandemic in the
sense
that we're going to live with it forever
it's going to be a large part
well hopefully it'll be a smaller and
smaller part of our life but
uh this is going to be something like
the common cold it's never
gonna go away it's probably gonna take
years and years and years to go away and
by that time we'll have had an economic
collapse
um and we'll be uh you know
probably some cyber war with china or
something i don't know uh and uh we just
need uh to get to the point where things
get so bad that kova gets knocked down
that's like remember during the riots
covent was like the fourth story
we need that again yeah remember that
covid was the fourth story
because literally there were people
marching through the streets burning
down buildings
now that things are relatively peaceful
covets back to being number one
the answer is not treatments or vaccines
the answer is
more civil unrest riots
burning of the buildings murder arson
because then what happens is kova just
stops being important remember that when
it stopped being important
yeah no one cared they were like the
real pandemic has raised us up
and and so people could march and so we
just
we just need that somebody if you could
because i don't want this to happen in
real life somebody if you could
cgi a couple of white cops shooting an
innocent guy
i want to cure covet can someone release
a scene from a movie
and will say it's real shut up maybe we
should do this to kirkovic okay
i look like a cop i just execute an
innocent black family in a car
for no reason again i'm against this
for the simple reason that we put that
video out
coat the delta gamma lambda
lamborghini all of it will go away it'll
be gone because that's what happened
last time
so what we need is uh police to shoot
an unarmed person i don't want any of
this to happen
but do you see what i'm saying here if
it were to happen
we'd probably get over the delta variant
very quickly
we'd all start to realize that the real
pandemic is racism
because those are the articles being
written the real pandemics
so we just maybe nobody even has to die
can a [ __ ] go yell at a black guy in a
uh grocery store and put it go viral
we need it take one for the team if
you're a white [ __ ]
take one for the team get a black friend
of yours go to a store a grocery store
and just
yell at them and make it go viral
because we need
to get over this covet hump and the only
way that we're going to do that
is uh by diverting the attention to the
real pandemic
which is racism that's the way we got
over it remember covid last year didn't
exist
no you you didn't go outside
because you thought you would be uh
killed by a violent mob
you can't have it all you understand
what i mean you can't have it all
but do you want covered or do you not
want if you don't want coven
we got to have violent mobs in the
street again that's
that's where we're at that's
it's funny but that's the options you
have as a citizenry
would you like would you spin the wheel
tell them what they've won
well we've got two prizes for you a
forever lockdown
with 90 million streams of golfing or
eruptions of violence mob violence in
the street
what would you like those are the
options
we can have a forever lockdown with 20
million strains of coven
and the media reporting on everyone
who's dying
uh uh you know the media with the camera
in the face can you breathe
um we can have that that's what we're
heading towards
or b we can have riots in the street
lighting cop cars on fire but at least
there's no covered you won't be able to
leave
uh and you'll every now and then you'll
be eating at a restaurant because
because covert will go away you'll be
able to eat in a restaurant
but then molotovs will come on in uh
while you're eating your uh uh
tuna tartare but those are the uh it's
seemingly the options am i wrong
if i was an alien and just looked at the
last year of history the options are
spikes of covid or violence in the
street
what what shall we take i'm ready for a
little let's have a little violence in
the street
let's take the masks off let's let's
douse a few cop cars with kerosene
light it up because those will be your
choices as an american citizen
that and that is what they call pay
attention
a failed state
when your options are an incompetent
federal government
completely mismanaging a pandemic
destroying your lives and livelihoods
or the federal government taking a break
from that
to sanction mass violence to also
destroy your lives and livelihoods
those are your two choices what's fun
about both of them is they both
end in your lives and livelihoods uh
being destroyed
but you can avoid all that if you're in
sports
because if you don't think about all
that and you just get up every day and
you do
sports
if you do sports and you watch sports
people love watching sports oh yeah ray
watches sports now he's 900 pounds he's
big into basketball he knows he's
honorable
big into everything he's big into a
chair
and and and and he enjoys it and people
love it so
that's why the sport that's why uh uh
simone biles and uh
uh yokozuna
the tennis player naomi osaka
who cares there's enough people that
think i'm racist anyway
it doesn't really matter you've got
bigger problems imagine it's gonna you
know
being somewhat uh i don't want to say
famous but whatever i happen to be
whatever
well it's just every day you wake up and
you realize why you're like
three reasons you're a nazi and you go
ah
because the definition of nazi changes
now so frequently while you sleep
that you just wake up and it's like
covet you wake up and you go
what are the symptoms of it now what are
the symptoms of nazi now
i think maybe we should have a police
force i think penises and vaginas are
inherently different
ah it's like covid kova they go it's
runny nose now
and now you wake up and they go nazi
means you believe in a border now
oh well but
um naomi osaka these they don't realize
how important they are they're so
important because
i don't come to these disturbing
realizations about life
when i can just a watch an athlete in
their prime
physical condition there's nothing
better than a prime physical specimen
because it connects us to nature
it connects us to what we really should
be which is stupid
the best things about life are silly
[ __ ] and eating and [ __ ]
those are the most fun things um when we
start to get too
high-minded about things we start to
destroy ourselves in our collective
civilization
so the reason that athletes are so
important it's not only that it's a
distraction it connects us
to when we were young and we would just
run in a field or swim and you
you felt good you were connected to your
body before you polluted it and
destroyed it with pills and food and
booze and drugs and this and that
and tattoos get the tattoos off they
look like
[ __ ] but i mean is there anything worse
than being really hot than putting
tattoos on you i mean it's grotesque
my point is this um
nobu the tennis player
and and uh simon beale
biles beals biles beals biles peels
simon
simon they don't realize how important
they are
because they connect us to a deeper
truth about ourselves
and it is not it is not simply a
distraction it is they are the perfect
the ideal we all want to be
uh stupid truly
be stupid for us show us the way
show us how to just sweat and shred
and cut and kill and win
girls boys anyone in between and most
athletes are
athletes are like naturally trans the
masculine male athletes are very light
on their feet
and kind of um what's the word i'm
looking for
uh graceful yeah correct
and the female athletes many of them are
hulking
husky voices naturally trans
they're the evolution of the body
perfect
that's what we need we need to see the
body the body
in in perfect um you know
uh agreement with the mind
the body and the mind working uh hand in
hand
synchronized perfectly and in order to
do that
we need to shut off our minds
shut them off turn
what is this laguna beach
hello good afternoon this is alana
calling from the lofts at montana beach
how are you i'm great how are you
good we are just calling to say that
we received an email and trying to make
a reservation for you tonight
um and we were wondering if 545 would be
all right with you
unfortunately we we can't uh come
the couple that was going to come uh to
have dinner with us
unfortunately uh has uh you know been in
a car accident and they've been horribly
mangled
oh yes um
so should i cancel that for you
i mean i may still go you have the
rotisserie chicken right
sorry you have the rotisserie chicken
still on that menu
i believe we do and that's good that
chicken's good if you had it with the
fava beans
[Music]
let's see
yes we still do have our rotisserie
chicken okay so you know we're gonna
find another couple can we do four at
five pm
four at five pm yes thank you so much
it's very sad what happened but they
weren't a fun couple anyway
right it all works out for the best
i guess doesn't it always yeah
thank you dear four and five
yes
we must compete uh the sports people
have to show up for work and it is not
because
we want them to injure themselves or
others is because they connect us to a
reality
uh that we can many of us can no longer
live in
and that reality is of the body
not of the mind not of the mind great
feats of
the body the mental acuity to direct
your body to
do great things that's great
the world of the mind is littered now
with uh
garbage and probably never will
go back to being anything other than
just a circle jerk
the mind is the problem shut it off
and hit the ball go over the net
go over the net just shh just quiet
just quiet now like if i was a mobile's
coach would say
just quiet down don't think about 9 11
don't think about your life don't think
about if anyone really loves you
don't think about what love is anyway
don't think about what happens after you
die
don't think about your family don't
think about your friends
don't think about your fans don't think
of your community
the community of man don't think about
what we are don't pay attention to that
weird feeling you have
in the back of your leg it's all
[ __ ]
none of it matters just shh
look at me look at me don't think about
the fact that they're not letting you
take out of all these freaks
don't think about that [ __ ] pedophile
don't think about that everyone's
pedophile
just sh balance on the bar
balance on the bar and you do a flip
and you trust you trust
that you're going to land that flip and
you know why you're going to land that
flip i'll tell you why you're going to
land that flip
i'll tell you why you're going to land
that flip because if you can
shut your mind off and you just let your
body take over
okay you will get
the results that you've been getting for
the entire time
you just you can do it you can do it
because
we need you to do it we have so little
left simone
we need a champion we need a champion
and and you are our our champion
so if this comes up again just learn to
quiet
your mind don't think about that kid
doing a parkland shooting and lying to
his father
think about any of it just get out there
and do something that is
meaningless and stupid but do it
perfectly
do it perfectly because simone
that's life it's meaningless
it's silly but when you watch someone do
it perfectly
it's still impressive good luck out
there
don't get sick get smart